&gt;&gt; So you're pretty proficient at this point at multiplying polynomials
together. And then of course simplifying what you get. But if we can work from
having two binomials. Binomials are just polynomials with two terms in them. We
can work from having those multiplied together to having something that looks
sort of quadratic. We should be able to start with something quadratic and work
backwards, to having binomials multiplied together. And the problem with Grant,
we're trying to go that direction. So let's say we have some simple quadratic
expressions, like x squared, plus 5x, plus 6. Can we figure out how to factor
this, based on patterns in the above equation? The x squareds correspond
directly, and the 6, and the ab, are both constant terms, so they must go
together. If this middle term, the 5x and ax plus bx that are going to be a
little bit more tricky. So let's focus on this part of the term.